were those specific songs scripted from
the start or
are those songs you decided on after the
fact
yeah you know what was surprising i
usually don't use music
i use composition um you know that's
that's usually my go-to and
the composer for the series uh you know
was
was remarkable and and he did seven
seconds my other show
but when i was writing this because
because the coiby format
uh necessitates a very propulsive
type of storytelling that again is
usually not my jam
this whole other part i think opened up
of using music
you know and in a city like los angeles
you know we drive around with a radio
plane we hear
you know other people's radios playing
you we hear music on the street
and so um i you know
from the from the get-go you know it was
an homage to
to the city of los angeles you know and
to into the music that's come from the
city
and also it started out too california
dreaming was the very first
piece that i thought of when i was
thinking of claire
and a huge part is because i was also
thinking
of wanker y and um
who's another giant influence on the
film besides collateral
um and nightcrawler and and so i was
thinking about
california dreaming and then i heard
other versions of it
and then i heard uh yeah so it was just
like i was hearing music
and writing and in this like energetic
space
and and the songs just kept coming i
have two follow-ups that i don't want to
forget to ask so
california dreaming but then when did
you decide to have that song
bookend the film and why from two
different artists
i wanted claire to change you know she
was a different woman
uh then she she at the end and she
wasn't being radically different
and so california dreaming by the moms
and the papas have like a hopefulness
you know especially in the wong kar y
film an openness hopefulness naivete
sweetness
um that she no longer possesses
at the end of the film we're good and so
i wanted a very different type
you know she came to california the
character with a dream
and this is the new dream you know that
she gets in this kind of
you know city of of dreams
[Music]
[Applause]